For this programming assignment, you needed to have rearranged the
levels of the age.range variable, so that way, under 18 appeared
first. One way to do this is to use the ordered
function on the variable. We'll use the ordered function on age.range,
and then we'll set the levels. I can run all
this code to set the levels, and then, I can make
my plot again. Pretty nice, huh? Another way to achieve the
same result would be to use this code. Here, we're using
the factor function. We're taking our age.range variable,
setting the levels, and then making the order
be true since we want these ordered. I'll
run this code. And then, I'll make sure that
the graph is the same output. And yes,
it is. Now, if you want another challenge, try
reordering the levels for the income range variable,
and see if you can produce this same plot.